bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mardi 2 février
astrazeneca le vaccin autorisé en france
mais pas recommandée ou plus de 65 ans
décision de l'aes ce soir de quoi
rebattre les cartes de la stratégie
vaccinale française paris pourrait bien
se tourner du côté russe selon la revue
médicale de référence the lancet validé
par des experts indépendants le vaccin
spoutnik v serait efficace à plus de 91
% la plus haute validation
scientifiquement possible angela merkel
affirme que tous les vaccins autorisés
seront elles les bienvenus
[Musique]
2022 et la présidentielle en ligne de
mire des manuels macron l'elysée a
récemment lancé une cellule dédiée à la
lutte contre la désinformation honfleur
c'est son nom identifie des prestataires
privés susceptibles de protéger les
fêtes news une structure qui suscite des
craintes au sein du renseignement ce
sera l'objet de l'édito des lexiques
poulain dans quelques instants
[Musique]
retour aujourd'hui au sénat du projet de
loi bioéthique une deuxième lecture
après avoir adopté par été adoptée par
l'assemblée cet été au coeur des débats
l'ouverture de la pma toutes les femmes
ainsi que la question de la filiation
après agnès buzyn c'est olivier verrons
qui est désormais en première ligne pour
défendre le texte
[Musique]
l'opposant alexeï navalni condamné à
trois ans et demi de prison par le
tribunal de moscou ses partisans ont
appelé à descendre immédiatement dans la
rue le détracteur du kremlin est
condamnée pour ne pas avoir respecté les
conditions de son contrôle judiciaire
paris londres berlin et washington
appelle à sa libération immédiate nous
serons en direct depuis moscou
[Musique]
deux informations importantes liées à la
lutte contre le coronavirus aujourd'hui
donc le vexin russe efficace à 91% selon
la revue de référence scientifique the
lancet tu es puis en france ce nouveau
vaccin celui destraz et les cas qui
vient d'être autorisé le troisième après
pfizer bio ntech et moderna pour plus de
précision on retrouve tout de suite en
direct david kelly phare en direct
depuis la haute autorité de santé qui a
donc donné cette autorisation david
quelles sont les recommandations pour
astrazeneca et bien durant la conférence
de presse cet après midi la présidente
de la haute autorité à 2 santé a affirmé
que le vaccin astrazeneca représente une
performance entre 62 et 70 % assez
satisfaisant pour sa mise sur le marché
français il devient donc le troisième
vaccin être autorisée sur notre
territoire
en revanche comme on pouvait s y
attendre son administration n'est pas
recommandé aux plus de 65 ans mis en
cause en allemagne notamment son
efficacité ne serait que de 8 % chez les
personnes de plus de 65 ans a les
données manquent encore pour le moment
la haute autorité de santé recommande
donc de vacciner tous les professionnels
médical ainsi que les personnes allant
de 50 à 65 ans présentant des risques
autre point important il pourra être
administrée par les pharmaciens et les
sages-femmes en plus des infirmiers et
des
médecin à noter qui peut être stocké à
long terme dans des frigos classique ce
qui facilite son déploiement logistique
par rapport aux deux autres vaccins et
la mise sur le marché david de ce vaccin
va t'elle régler la pénurie qui existe
actuellement
et bien malheureusement non puisque
avant d'ouvrir ce nouveau canal d'accès
à la vaccination il faudra disposer de
suffisamment de 12 et la livraison ne se
fera pas tout de suite est la france
table et mardi dernier sur seulement 4,6
millions de doses soit 29% de commandes
promises d'ici fin mars
les livraisons arrivent donc arrivons
donc au compte goutte une solution
naturelle se présentent au gouvernement
français c'est le vaccin est russe
efficace à 91,1 6% selon une étude de la
revue médicale the lands est validée par
des experts indépendants du côté de
l'allemagne l'est déjà le bienvenu selon
les mots d'anglais la merkel si l'
agence européenne du médicament
le valier d'écouté est d'ailleurs à ce
propos le leader de la france insoumise
jean luc mélenchon ça va se faire les
allemands ont décidé donc jarre sera
le président français n'a plus aucune
autorité dans ce domaine je préfère
aussi d'ailleurs je voudrais vous
rappeler que les russes en début de
crise on proposer aux français une co
production de vaccins et que ensuite ils
ont été le proposer aux argentins il
faut suivre ces questions c'est
intéressant ce que font les autres
gouvernements et pas en restant dedans
ce nombrilisme aiguë dans lequel sont
les autorités françaises qui contre
toute raison se targue d'avoir fait des
réussites de tout seul alors il y à un
vaccin russe qui fonctionne il y aura il
ya un vaccin français qui arrivent sur
le marché dont il faut que tout
toutes ces possibilités sont explorées
par l'union européenne mais j'ai vu que
madame merkel qui est plus réaliste que
monsieur macron a pris langue avec le
monsieur qui tient pour traiter de cette
histoire de papiers
donc je suppose que tous les autres vont
se mettre au garde à vous maintenant est
bon par l'écouté si c'est madame merkel
qui fumait revendications mieux que
monsieur macron je n'y vois pas
d'inconvénient
même son de cloche pour marine le pen
sur twitter la présidente du
rassemblement national interpelle le
gouvernement sur l'efficacité du
spoutnik vl demande de travailler en
bonne intelligence avec la russie et ne
pas laisser l'idéologie ruiner nos
capacités à vacciner nos compatriotes
voilà en tout cas les quarts sont
totalement rebattues avec cette annonce
du dieu de la revue de 2,97 médical et
le gouvernement va peut-être devoir
changer de fusil d'épaulé dans sa
stratégie de vaccination
merci david khalifa en direct de la
haute autorité de santé et vous le
disiez à l'instant le vexin russo
efficace à 91e une 6% contre les formes
symptomatiques du coc vie 19 ce sont
donc les résultats publiés aujourd'hui
dans la revue médicale de référence de
l'inde cette photo nick v considérez
donc comme une nouvelle arme pour
combattre l'épidémie est actuellement
utilisée en russie en argentine ou
encore en algérie le vaccin russe attend
désormais l'aval de l'agencé européenne
des médicaments
wally bennani sûr et efficace
deux mots qui pourraient bien changer la
trajectoire du vaccin russe spoutnik v
la revue hebdomadaire scientifique est
respectée hollande 7 dans un coup de
projecteur aux scientifiques russes le
développement du vaccin spoutnik v a été
critiquée par sa précipitation le fait
qu'il ait brûlé les étapes et une
absence de transparence mais les
résultats rapportés ici sont claires et
le principe scientifique de cette
vaccination est démontrée déclarations
de deux spécialistes britanniques après
le dernier stade des essais cliniques du
vaccin
la phase 3 qui porte sur près de vingt
mille participants
des essais menés notamment par des
scientifiques indépendants de doses ont
été administrées à trois semaines
d'intervalle et un constat spoutnik
verts réduits de 91,6 % le risque de
contracter une formes symptomatiques du
kovy 19,97 insiste tout de même sur
l'importance de continuer ses recherches
notamment sur les personnes ne
présentant pas de symptômes
j'estime que c'est effectivement une
réalisations monumentales pour la russie
mais aussi pour le monde entier parce
qu'il n'y a à l'heure actuelle que trois
vaccins dans le monde dont l'efficacité
dépasse 90% unique v et l'inde eut en
plus son efficacité contre les cas
graves et de 100%
c'est donc une réalisation effectivement
très importante et nous sommes
reconnaissants à la revue zealand 7
cela montre qu'elle n'est pas guidée par
des motivations politiques mais par la
science et le désir de faire de la
science de qualité et de trouver une
solution
j'estime donc que c'est une réussite
très importante satisfaction du côté de
moscou et pression désormais du côté de
l' agence européenne du médicament une
demande d'homologation il ya été déposée
le 20 janvier
selon le fonds d'investissements directs
russe chargée de commercialiser spoutnik
vais au moins 15 pays se sont tournés
vers la russie
[Musique]
c'est mon fils qui m'a parlé de la
vaccination et j'en étais très heureux
alors je suis venu aussi vite que j'ai
pu au moins cela nous permettra de nous
reposer un peu pour ne plus subir le
stress d'être si prudent toute la
journée
que dieu nous protège de ce fléau
aujourd'hui les boliviens peuvent
respirer tranquillement peuvent
recommencer à vivre lentement et
progressivement la chasse centralisée de
vaccins à bruxelles a échoué
cela met en danger la vie des européens
et la relance rapide de l'économie
européenne
c'est pourquoi nous avons cherché de
nouvelles sources d'approvisionnement
nous avons été les premiers mais il est
peu probable que nous soyons les seuls
dans l'union européenne à participer à
cet effort et l'autre
même soulagement pour le kazakhstan le
fonds d'investissements directs russe
promet qu'il peut fournir à l'union
européenne 100 millions de doses de son
vaccin pour 50 millions de personnes au
deuxième trimestre 2021
ce mardi la chancelière angela merkel a
informé que tous les vaccins autorisés
seront les bienvenues en allemagne et
alors que la pénurie de vaccins gâté 27
l'europe regarde désormais avec beaucoup
d'intérêt beaucoup plus je dirais même
le vaccin russe doit-on en acheter pour
compenser par exemple aidé aux pré
commandé par l'union européenne à sanofi
et qui n'arriveront peut-être jamais la
france et l'europe doivent tel revoir
leur stratégie vaccinale place à notre
décryptage avec nos invités
[Musique]
pour en parler nous sommes avec philippe
besset présidents des fédérations des
syndicats pharmaceutiques de france
guillaume klossa président et fondateur
du think tank européen europanova enfin
laurent alexandre chirurgien essayiste
laurent alexandre qui est également
l'auteur d'une tribune sur la
vaccination intitulé break site un
bruxelles 0 à lire dans les colonnes du
figaro ce week-end vous nous expliquerez
laurent alexandre pourquoi dans quelques
instants bonsoir en tout cas tous les
trois messieurs et merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france donc deux
spécialistes britanniques 1 qui ont
donné leur feu vert au vaccin russe
aujourd'hui dans les colonnes du lancet
tu regardais le commentaire d'un des
experts indépendants juin à l'étude est
plus le développement du vaccin spoutnik
v a été critiqué pour sa précipitation
le fait qu'il ait brûler des étapes et
une absence de transparence mais les
résultats rapportés ici sont claires et
le principe scientifique de cette
vaccination est démontré un peu de 91%
en effet qui a cité donc pour ce vaccin
c'est une bonne nouvelle en tout cas
dans la lutte contre l'épidémie
ducobu d'un candidat vaccin sérieux de
plus sur le marché on ne va pas s'en
plaindre laurent alexandre écoutez si
les données qui ont été montrés dans le
land 7 sont confirmées par les l'agencé
européenne du médicament et la f10 et
aux états unis on pourra avoir parfaite
conscience dans ce vaccin qui a une
efficacité supérieure aux autres vaccins
que les vaccins rn 10 ans le spoutnik
dans les données dont on dispose
aujourd'hui est un petit peu inférieur
aux vaccins arn messager qui sont plutôt
autour de 95%
mais il a une efficacité qui est
supérieur nettement supérieur à l'astra
zeneca dont l'efficacité moyenne chez
les gens jeunes et franchement médiocre
chez les gens âgés qui sont les gens les
plus fragiles alors le sporting des 1,40
très officiellement dans le club très
fermé des vaccins efficaces à plus de
90% bien qu'on attendait évidemment les
autorisations sur le marché en europe il
n'y en a que 3 je vous le rappelle un
terrain occupé jusqu alors surtout par
les américains on sait vous ne voyez sur
cet écran que la course en au vaccin est
devenu non seulement un enjeu de santé
publique évident mais aussi un enjeu
géopolitique pour tous les états la
reconnaissance du nantes 7 est donc très
importante
guillaume klossa pour la distribution
future du spo congrès d'abord qui est
qui plusieurs candidats la bonne chose
quelque chose pour l'humanité c'est une
bonne chose pour l'union européenne qui
avait une stratégie de diversification
mais reconnaissante du lone secte ne
vaut pas reconnaissance européenne du
médicament et c'est cette reconnaissance
qui est qui et il critique et si les
données du dans cette vue l'indépendance
et pénalités de l'agencé du médicament
je n'ai aucun doute sur le fait que le
vaccin russe aux rares l'homologation
européenne
ça veut dire qu'on ne fait pas de
politique en la matière laurent
alexandre on peut avoir confiance en
l'indépendance justement de l'agencé
européenne du médicament sur ce point là
l'agencé européenne du médicament comme
la f10 aux états unis est totalement
indépendante et donc si lorsqu'elle va
avoir accès aux données sources qu'elle
va pouvoir faire du data management sur
les données russe
elle confirme les chiffres qui ont été
avancés dans le lens est il n'y a aucun
doute qu'elle autorisera le vaccin russe
ce d'autant qu'aujourd'hui l'europe peut
difficilement faire sa chochotte
parce que compte tenu de l'échec
cinglant de la commission européenne en
matière d'achats de vaccins
il faut rappeler que l'europe vaccine
aujourd'hui 25 fois moins vite qu israël
cette fois moins vite que l'angleterre
de boris johnson et quatre fois moins
vite que les états unis d'amérique
compte tenu de ce plantage lamentable de
l'union européenne qui a signé les
contrats
trois mois après les autres pays parce
qu'il fallait l'accord des 27
un compte tenu de ce plantage l'europe
de toute façon on ne peut pas faire de
la politique
elle est obligée de faire de la
realpolitik c'est à dire de prendre les
vaccins là où ils sont et le spoutnik si
les données du l'ancêtre sont confirmés
est une option qui va être
incontournable
on voit bien d'ailleurs que les
politiciens et les chefs d'état en
europe sont en train de paniquer car la
réalité de la stratégie vaccinale compte
tenu de l'échec des achats de vaccins
par la commission européenne
c'est comme union européenne est en
train de confiner sens vacciné pour
l'opinion publique c'est démoralisant il
n'y a aucune perspective on confine les
gens mais on ne ne sort pas du tunnel
parce qu'il n'y a pas de vaccin il faut
savoir qu'à l'heure actuelle au 1er mars
par exemple la france n'aura fait la
première vaccination qu'à 2,5 millions
de français
c'est à dire une part infinitésimale des
français et au 1er avril
il est prévu 8 millions de gens vaccinés
c'est à dire 12 % des français on sait
que l'immunité collective est très très
très loin
à la même époque israël aura totalement
terminé son programme d'action halle et
l'angleterre sera très très avancé donc
aujourd'hui on n'a pas le choix il va
falloir accueillir le spoutnik 5
si les chiffres sont confirmés et les
européens seront contents de sortir un
petit peu du tunnel grâce à la
technologie russe parce que ils ont
tellement échoué dans leur stratégie de
contrats qu'ils n'ont absolument pas le
choix et je le répète
l'europe ne va pas pouvoir faire sa
chochotte alors en tout cas on se fait
davantage les hyènes elle répond à ces
critiques que vous venez de mentionner
laurent alexandre mais évidemment vous
n'êtes pas le seul la présidente de la
commission européenne qui se défendent
s'est exprimé dans les colonnes du monde
hier regardez certains pays ont commencé
à vacciner un peu avant l'europe c'est
vrai mais ils ont eu recours à des
procédures d'autorisation de mise sur le
marché d'urgence en 24 heures la
commission et les états membres étaient
d'accord pour ne pas transiger avec les
exigences de sécurité et d'efficacité
qui sont liées à l'autorisation d'un
vaccin
l'europe est parti plus tard mais
c'était la bonne décision
enfin philippe besset la lenteur
vaccinale à l est du à quoi selon vous
vous y croyez à la défense d'arsenal van
der leyen la faute à la stratégie
européenne ou la faute aux labos qui
livrent avec du retard selon vous
je suis d'accord avec le fait que les
états doivent prendre leurs précautions
pour garantir la confiance et pour
garantir le fait que les gens aillent au
vaccin
la confiance dans la vaccination la
confiance dans les dents les autorités
de santé des dents les soignants elle et
elle est garantie par par le sérieux des
agences moi je serais très content que
tous les vaccins qui passent le cap de
la barrière de le m&a et en europe
puissent rentrer dans la stratégie
vaccinale des états ça c'est certain
en revanche je suis obligé de dire qu'il
ya quelque chose de faux dans ce que
vous avez dit sur le vaccin astrazeneca
dans votre reportage initial vous avez
repris une erreur des médias allemands
sur le fameux 8%
en fait ce qui s'est passé si kylie à 8
% de patients âgés dans l'étude
d'astrazeneca
c'est ça celui % et donc le m&a a dit il
ya trop peu de gens dans l'étude
initiale pour dire qu' il faut vacciner
au delà de 65 ans avec ce vaccin
astrazeneca
mais elle a dit aussi l' agence
européenne et la haute autorité de santé
l'a dit cet après midi que très
rapidement ils vont revoir cette
préconisation au regard des des
vaccinations en angleterre et dans le
reste du monde qui vaccine les plus de
65 ans avec avec ces vaccins là donc je
résume
c'est une très bonne nouvelle que tous
les vaccins du monde entier soit au
rendez-vous de la vaccination nous avons
besoin de deux
nous avons les bras pour vacciner nous
avons les français qui veulent se faire
vacciner
donc ce qu'il nous faut c'est des doses
de vaccin donc il faut que les agences
européennes le fasse avec le plus grand
sérieux mais il faut qu'elle le fasse
vite
nous avons besoin de deux rapidement sur
le sol français pour vacciner les
français
est-ce qu'on n'aurait pas pu s'y prendre
avant guillaume klossa clairement on a
entendu jean luc mélenchon mot dire
la russie avait proposé une coopération
à la france on arrive maintenant qu'on
est en retard
s'ouvrir au reste du monde un peu plus
plusieurs choses d'abord si on a trouvé
rapidement des vaccins notamment le
vaccin braiseurs et le bassin oxford
astrazeneca ces deux vaccins bon et et
ce n'est pas par de l'argent européen
l'argent du million european research
council et ça fait des années que dure
européen 10h40 s'il a investi comme ça
il faut le dire parce que personne ne le
dit
deuxièmement pour la confiance vaccinale
le fait que les européens aient envie de
se faire vacciner
c'est une bonne chose d'avoir une agence
européenne dans lequel on a confiance et
troisièmement rien empêché les états
rien empêché les états comme la hongrie
la fait d'avoir des approvisionnement
supplémentaire mais imaginez que la
france ait eu sa propre stratégie
d'approvisionnement nous aurions des
pendus massivement sur des vaccins
sanofi et y aurait eu un regard au
général europe
le quatrième point c'est que si on
regarde les 12 premiers pays qui ont le
plus actionner la moitié sont des pays
de l'union européenne donc faut pas non
plus caricaturer les européens sont des
bons vaccinateurs mais il ya quelques
pays notamment la france
ils sont très en retard et donc il faut
pas refaire de l'europe un bouc
émissaire
je suis d'accord sur le fait que moi si
j'avais été en situation et quand le
conseil européen a missionné la
commission européenne j'aurais vérifier
qu'elles se dotent des moyens des
compétences pour signer et négocier ses
contrats elle ne l'a pas fait et aucun
d'états membres n'avaient ni à le faire
donc la responsabilité et les sueurs les
états membres est-ce que moi j'aurais
préconisé c'est soit la création d'une
task force indépendante soit la création
d'une agence vaccinale qui soit
indépendante et qui est une stratégie de
diversification et c'est le fait que
l'union européenne n'est pas une
compétence dans ce domaine qui a fait
que eh bien on a
on a bricolé alors laurent alexandre va
peut-être être moins indulgent que vous
laurent alexandre on ne revient cette
fameuse tribune publiée ce week-end
break site un bruxelles 0 on va voir
cette tribune et vous écrivez
donc dans la course au vaccin nous avons
été naïf maladroit et peu pragmatique ça
veut dire quoi concrètement laurent
alexandre que les anglais ont été
meilleurs que nous déclencher le break
site leur a permis d'échapper à la
lourdeur administrative de cette tribune
que nous avons écrit avec eux nicolas
bouzou été olivier babeau nous avons
effectivement été sévère la commission
européenne et l'interview de dans le
monde de sa présidente hier montre que
l'union est en déni complet puisque
l'interview dans le monde explique que
la stratégie européenne est la meilleure
qu'elle est bonne et que c'était le bon
choix
en réalité c'est peut-être le bon choix
d'un point de vue des procédures
bureaucratiques mais en termes de doses
disponibles
c'est lamentable netanyahu à 814
millions de doses après avoir téléphoné
personnellement qu'à 17 fois au patron
de pfizer l'angleterre à un nombre
illimité de doser les états unis n'ont
aucune pénurie de doses donc l'europe a
mal négocié le contrat
elle n'avait pas de spécialiste du droit
privé pour négocier et elle a fait
croire qu'elle avait la compétence aux
émis aux états membres qui lui ont
délégué cette charge
aujourd'hui il serait bon que la
président de la commission reconnaisse
qu'elle s'est trompée que sa stratégie a
été mauvaise qu'elle demande pardon et
qu'elle explique comment elle va
corriger ces erreurs
parce que le déni délirant dans lequel
la commission est rentré de dire on est
les meilleurs parce qu'on vaccine
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup moins que
d'autres pays comme israël l'angleterre
et les états unis est intenable et pour
un europe un pro européen comme je le
suis c'est scandaleux et d'ailleurs dans
mon entourage tous les pro européens que
je connais à bruxelles et en france sont
scandalisés par l'attitude de la
commission qui refuse de reconnaître
qu'elle s'est planté on peut toujours se
tromper mais sur un enjeu de vielles de
mort comme l'est la vaccination un
deviez de mort économique mais également
sanitaires il est inacceptable qu'il y
avait eu un tel dérapage et qu'il n'y a
pas de remise en courant en question de
de l'union aujourd'hui ce qui me paraît
important c'est qu'on corrige le tir et
que la commission reconnaisse qu'elle
s'est trompée parce que si elle ne
reconnaît pas son air
initial elle ne va pas bien corriger le
tir aujourd'hui il faut vacciner plus
vite dans de nombreux pays l'opinion est
à bout et elle n'a plus de perspective
vous avez vu pas très loin de chez moi
en landes dans un pays qui
traditionnellement est très très calme
il ya eu des émaux de grave il y a même
eu des incendies massif des garages à
vélos pour qu'aux pays bas on incendie
les garages à vélos il faut vraiment que
l'opinion soit très mécontents donc
aujourd'hui il faut vraiment qu'on
corrige le tir
il faut qu'on bénéficie de tous les
vaccins dont la nba et est là
lagence européenne sur lequel ils ont
donné leur accord
il faut faire vite parce que nous ne
pouvons pas supporter un confinement
pendant et des mois et des mois et
compte tenu de l'état des contrats que
l'union européenne a signé de la
disponibilité des doses
on est parti aujourd'hui pour finir la
vaccination à noël 2021 au mieux et
c'est inacceptable
cl acceptable il faut aller plus vite et
à l'intérieur de l'europe évidemment il
y a à la france qui n'affiche pas pour
le moment un bilan très brillant on le
sait pasteur qui a jeté l éponge
sanofi qui va être très en retard et
puis cet élu nantaise qui a publié une
tribune aujourd'hui dans ouest france
elle se plaignait que la france n'ait
pas accordé de subventions à son
laboratoire un valbuena et du coup ce
même laboratoire préfèrent vendre ses
doses à au royaume uni on les retrouve
là philippe besset clairement la france
est elle en échec sur le plan vaccinal
aujourd'hui écoutez je ne suis pas un
commentateur bon je suis dans l'action
je suis un responsable donc d'une
organisation professionnelle qui sont
les pharmaciens d'officine
nous nous sommes pleinement mobilisés
j'ai déjà que j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de
le dire sur votre antenne pour pour les
masques et ensuite et ensuite pour pour
l'ensemble des dispositifs le le sujet
actuellement c'est effectivement de
vacciner je suis d'accord que nous avons
besoin de deux donc le je ne suis plus
on fera évidemment un retex évidemment
il est important et la démocratie et là
nous avons des instances il y aura
j'imagine
commission denquête comme il ya eu une
commission d' enquête sur les masques
pour vérifier les responsabilités de
chacun c'est pas le sujet du jour
le sujet du jour c'est de vacciner donc
s'il faut améliorer la rapidité
nan nan franchement là que le monde
je comprends que vous ayez pas envie de
vous voilà vous prononcez parlant c'est
pas votre hall sarsat je l'entends bien
enfin c'est quand même le sujet du jour
vu qu'on a pas de assez de vaccins pour
vacciner mais d'ailleurs puisque voilà
je vous demande pas de vous prononcer
sur le sujet du jour
ex exactement astrazeneca d'ailleurs qui
va vous allez avoir accès vous les
pharmaciens justement c'est une bonne
nouvelle en tout cas pour vous d'être
enfin mis dans la boucle
c'est ça c'est ça c'est la bonne
nouvelle du jour c'est à dire qu'en fait
on a enfin un vaccin qui va pouvoir va
qu'on va pouvoir administrer au plus
près de la population
le moi je pense que c'est ça qui est
important c'est que l'ensemble de la
population française est accès aux
vaccins en proximité par les soignants
de ville par les médecins par les
infirmiers par les pharmaciens au plus
près on est en capacité de vacciner nous
on va dire 10 millions de personnes par
mois
donc effectivement là le vaccin astra et
tous les vaccins adénovirus qui arrive
maintenant qu'ils sont des vaccins
classiques qu'on peut garder dans nos
dans les frigos médicaux et qu'on peut
et qu'on peut donc administré beaucoup
plus simplement peuvent à permettre de
vacciner très vite
donc effectivement il faut les avoir
donc là je rejoins je vous rejoins il
faut maintenant que nous avons
l'accès à ces à ces doses il faut qu'on
les ait il faut se battre pour ça mais
la bonne nouvelle du jour c'est que ces
technologies maintenant arrive sur le
marché
moi je crois que si si les gouvernements
maintenant se secoue un peu pour pour
nous garantir des deux en arrivera avoir
vacciné avant l'été comme comme c'est
prévu merci en tout cas tous les trois
pour ce débat philippe besset guillaume
klossa et laurent alexandre merci
d'avoir été en direct avec nous sur
notre antenne et dans quelques instants
nous parlerons de honfleur ans est le
nom choisi pour la lutte contre la
désinformation elysées qui a récemment
lancé une cellule dédiée lexsi poulin
nous en dira plus dans sa rubrique
l'édito et puis direction le sénat au
projet de loi bioéthique est de retour
en deuxième lecture trois jours de débat
dans un climat bouleversé par la crise
sanitaire
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'elle outre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du public
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers une forme c'est quand
même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oublié
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu'il y a quand
même la liberté je vous remercie de
m'avoir invité
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
coups politiques n'a jamais été obligé
de dire la vérité d idée courageuse des
mots qui comptent en soi vient des
guignols
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrêmement
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
bienvenue en direct sur rt francs si
vous nous rejoignez il est 20h30 heure
française à 2022 et la présidentielle en
ligne de mire des manuels micron
l'elysée a récemment lancé une cellule
dédiée à la lutte contre la
désinformation honfleur c'est son nom
identifie les prestataires privés
susceptibles de provoquer pour propager
des fakes news
une structure qui suscite des craintes
au sein du renseignement c'est notre
rubrique l'édito ce soir un bon soir
alexis poulain merci d'être avec nous
alors emmanuel macron qui lance donc
fleurs 1 c'est le nom poétique de sa
task force anti-fn keynews oui oui on
apprend par le site spécialisé dans le
renseignement a une télé jones online
kemmel macron a lancé cette fameuse task
force contre la désinformation
baptisé honfleur et c'est le secrétariat
général de la défense et de la sécurité
nationale qui est en train de
sélectionner quelles pourraient être les
acteurs privés qui seront responsables
de cette lutte contre la désinformation
alors le problème est ce qui peut
inquiéter
c'est pourquoi choisir de donner cette
mission d'intérêt général à des acteurs
privés est ce qu'il ya pas là des
risques tout simplement de conflit
d'intérêts on l'a déjà vu et comment se
fait-il que ont choisi soudain c'est
cette lutte contre l'effet que news
quels acteurs privés va être sélectionné
peut-il s'agir par exemple du cabinet de
conseil mckinsey qui a déjà été choisi
par le gouvernement dans le cadre du
déroulement du plan vaccinal si c'est le
cas et si c'est mckeen's aigle il faut
savoir que cette entreprise a été payée
par le gouvernement saoudien en 2015
pour identifier et censurer des
opposants au régime
alors là on peut se poser la question du
choix politique de ses partenaires
privés et puis encore une fois entre les
cabinets de conseil et le pouvoir
beaucoup de porosité où certains hauts
cadres de mckinsey ont fait la campagne
d'e mails maquereau en 2017
et puis certains passent du cabinet de
conseil aux cabinets ministériels et
vice versa avec également les
plateformes qui n'hésite pas à recruter
dans le personnel politique
twitter qui récemment avait recruté
une attachée parlementaire la république
en marche et un ancien cadre de mckinsey
pour faire les acteurs publics alors
cette idée de tasses force elle pose
question mais elle s'inscrit aussi dans
la continuité puisque ce gouvernement
souhaite encadrer la liberté de la
presse et lutter contre la
désinformation il ya déjà eu la loi via
vous vous rappelez qui a été retoquée
par le conseil constitutionnel qui il
souhaitait lutter contre les discours de
haine en ligne avant cela il y avait
l'idée d'un conseil de déontologie de la
profession de journaliste qui avait été
rejeté par l'ensemble de la profession
et puis via le cadre de la loi sécurité
globale on voit que cette fois ci la
majorité veut un peu attaqué la loi 10
181 qui est le fondement de la liberté
de la presse donc vraiment à suivre de
près cette commission aux fleurs est en
marche se mettent aussi en ordre de
marche pour 2022 avec une task force sur
les réseaux sociaux et de nouveaux
visages le nouveau porte parole dans les
médias notamment
oui on a vu la nomination de deux
nouvelles porte parole féminine qui sont
partout présentes en compagnie des
ministres autorisés à importer les
éléments de langage quotidien sur les
plateaux des matinales
c'est là une façon de reprendre la main
sur le discours politique avec en plus
l'arrivée de nombreux militants
numérique sur les réseaux sociaux en
préparation bien évidemment de la
campagne de 2022 et là encore sur les
réseaux sociaux on peut se poser la
question
on a vu twitter censurer le compte du
président américain donald trump et de
nombreux de ses supporters et ça sans
vergogne de manière totalement est monté
en disant que c'était pour le bien de la
démocratie et récemment facebook autre
réseau social qui lui a dit petit à
petit un vbi lisez les contenus
politiques dans les fid dans les
actualités des utilisateurs en tant que
sans doute les utilisateurs de facebook
ne sont pas là pour la politique mais
plutôt pour les vidéos de panda ou de
chatons donc de quoi dépolitiser le
débat ou plutôt plus graves
privatiser le débat démocratique le
prendre en otage d'une certaine façon
parce que ce sont là les patrons de
milliardaire de certains réseaux sociaux
qui sont des enclos numérique qui décide
via les algorithmes qui peut être vue
qui ne peut pas être vu et ça va au delà
on a vu de la censure de compte
politique par exemple sur le réseau
twitter un compte qui s'appelle anonyme
citoyens qui partageait de nombreuses
vidéos des manifestations contre les
mesures liberticides dans le cadre du
coc vide et bien ce compte a été censuré
par twitter et continue d'être censuré
dans ses comptes de soutien et et
facebook encore une fois qu'il sent sur
certains comptes politiques sans plus
d'explications disant qu' ils sont
contraires aux règles de la communauté
mais il ya des lois et des lois qui
encadrent le débat politique notamment
la pluralité des paroles politiques
donc je ne vois pas comment faire
campagne en 2022 dans le cadre d'une
privatisation du débat par ces
plateformes
il ya là un vrai danger démocratique et
nous devons être extrêmement vigilants
alors est-ce à dire alexis qu'à un an et
quatre mois de la présidentielle
emmanuel macron est déjà en campagne
alors disons que le président se montre
prudent et s'il est en campagne s'est
discrètement tout ce qu'il fait et toute
son énergie est concentrée aujourd'hui à
ne pas être le seul responsable des
fiascos à répétition dans le cadre de la
gestion de la crise du coc vide fiasco
des masques fiasco du déconfinement
fiasco des tests fiasco du nombre de
doses de vaccins qui viennent à manquer
pour là il ya des fusibles
le professeur salomon religieux vers en
ait d'autres
l'idée c'est de dire qu'il n'est pas
responsable emmanuel macron se veut une
figure rassembleuse faire que tous les
français travaillent ensemble contre
cette crise sanitaire
alors que dans le même temps et bien son
gouvernement par le biais du ministre de
l'intérieur verbalisent les
automobilistes qui sont en retard après
18 heures ou bien les français qui font
des courses après 18 heures donc on est
en train de diviser tandis que lui
rassemble mais personne n'est dupe que
qui décide qui est l'arbitré final dans
les conseils de défense liées à la crise
sanitaire c'est bien emmanuel macron qui
fait les choix en dernier donc il est en
train de se positionner de tempérer les
ardeurs de certains qui voudraient aussi
se présenter et puis s'il veut se
représenter en 2022 il faut que cette
gestion de crise soit inattaquable il
faut que son bilan
soit présentable on a vu que cette crise
a coûté à donald trump une élection et
pour ce faire et bien une façon sûre de
ne pas se faire censurer par les réseaux
sociaux c'est de se les mettre dans la
poche et s'assurer un infaillible
soutien pour 2022
et je vois pas comment faire si jamais
les algorithmes ont déjà choisi leur
candidat et vous parler d' emmanuel
macron sur le front de la crise qu'il
devra régler en vue de la campagne
présidentielle
à l'instant justement le chef de l'état
qui promet un vaccin pour tous les
français qui le souhaite d'ici la fin de
l'été merci alexis poulain
éditorialistes heures direct sur rt
france le sénat le sénat entame
aujourd'hui la deuxième lecture du
projet de loi bioéthique ce texte
hautement sensible est de retour au
palais du luxembourg après avoir été
adopté par l'assemblée nationale cet été
au coeur des débats à l'ouverture de la
pma à toutes les femmes ainsi que la
question de la filiation
après agnès buzyn c'est désormais au
tour d'olivier verront le ministre de la
santé actuelle de le défendre le point à
paris avec notre reporter nadège
abderrazak entre l'assemblée nationale
et le sénat il y a plusieurs points de
divergences à commencer par la pma la
procréation médicalement assistée
les sénateurs sont favorables à
l'ouverture de la pma à toutes les
femmes mais pas pour sa prise en charge
par la sécurité sociale en ce qui
concerne les couples de femmes et les
femmes seules
ils souhaitent les sénateurs en effet la
limiter au seul motif médical par
conséquent aux seuls couples
hétérosexuels
je vous propose d'écouter plusieurs
sénateurs il y à une évolution de la
société à laquelle on ne peut pas
tourner le dos mais que nous sommes là
justement pour mettre en place ce qu'il
faut pour le permettre mais juste ce
qu'il faut et faire très très attention
aux dérives qui pourraient y avoir donc
c'est vraiment le rôle au sein de cette
commission spéciale de bioéthique du
sénat que nous avons souhaité c'est à
dire mettre des limites et des barrières
sans pour autant être rétrograde et en
permettant toutefois ces évolutions que
l'on constate malgré tout et qui sont
indéniables non il ne fait pas
l'unanimité auprès des deux chambres
il ne fait pas l'unanimité au sein des
chambres à elle-même ce qui est normal
c'est un projet de loi qui est un projet
de société et il n'y avait pas
d'unanimité dans la société non plus
lorsque les débats généraux de la
bioéthique ont eu lieu avant
l'établissement du projet de loi
c'est une aventure collective on voit
bien que ce qui était un bourreau d'il
ya 50 ans ne l'est plus aujourd'hui
réciproquement mais pourtant c'est de
pas faire de dégâts humains que on a des
moyens aujourd'hui de répondre à
beaucoup de questions notamment les
points de fertilité donc je pense que
c'est une bonne chose et ce qui
m'effraie 7 est pugnace it et cette
hargne avec laquelle les gens sont
contre je respecte le fait qu'il soit
contre et je vous cache pas que si j'ai
dit et je basculerai notre côté c'est à
dire au jeu bien plus jeunes militants
répondent que ça soit possible
la réforme de la filiation doit aussi
être débattue ici au palais bourbon avec
un nouveau mode pour les enfants de
couples de femmes la filiation sera
établie à l'égard de la femme qui a
accouché bien sa désignation dans l'acte
de naissance tandis que celle qui n'a
pas porté le bébé le sera par la
reconnaissance conjointe
en revanche les sénateurs ont réécrit
l'article concernant la filiation d'un
enfant né à l'étranger d'une gpa
gestation pour autrui une pratique
interdite en france
les sénateurs devraient aussi discuter
de l'accès aux origines des enfants nés
d'un don de gamètes donc ovules ou ou
spermatozoïdes les textes prévoient et
qu'il puisse en effet accéder à leur
majorité à des informations personnelles
voire à l'identité complète du donneur
sur le volet recherche les sénateurs
avaient interdit en commission la
création d'embryons transgénique est
chimérique ainsi que tout acte toute
techniques de modification les débats
vont durer trois jours ici et si les
sénateurs modifie à nouveau le texte des
élus des deux chambres donc sénat et
assemblée nationale devront se retrouver
en commission mixte paritaire pour
tenter de trouver un compris
oui mais il faut savoir et bien que le
dernier mot reviendra à l'assemblée
nationale en cas de désaccord persistant
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
franck bouverat un membre du collectif
marchon enfants bonsoir franck merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes donc opposés
à la loi bioéthique et vous avez
manifesté ce week-end à meaux qu'est ce
qui suscite le plus votre opposition
aujourd'hui alors déjà on pense que
cette loi passe en catimini un moment où
et parce que gouvernement autre chose à
faire que passer cette loi on est un
petit peu surpris a pas vraiment de deux
débats
et puis je ce qui nous agace le plus
c'est comment l'enfant est considérée
voilà on parle de on parle du droit et
des parents à avoir un enfant mais on
pense jamais à à ce que l'enfant lui et
c'est ce que je pense c'est le mieux
pour lui d'avoir un père et une mère est
dans le cadre d'une baignoire ou une gba
et ben c'est pas le cas
et donc je pense qu'on franchit une
ligne rouge et et je pense que c'est bon
on déconstruit quelque part quelque
chose et ça c'est dangereux
vous parlez du contexte dans lequel a
donc cette loi et discuter à nouveau
sénat ça va jouer ça va peser pour vous
d'une certaine manière ça va passer
inaperçu compte beaucoup sur les
sénateurs je sais qu'en seine-et-marne
par exemple ils sont très actifs ils ont
modifié s'il y avait été rédigé par
l'assemblée nationale
non je crois je pense qu'on est dans un
système de bicaméralisme ou dans lequel
le sénat son mot à dire
et le gouvernement ne doit pas faire un
traction de ce que nie le sénat je pense
notamment à tous qui est marchandisation
du corps humain
on le voit sur les images là à côté lors
de la manifestation de dimanche dernier
on voit ces bébés avec des dollars et
des codes-barres là aujourd'hui on
propose des banques de sperme ou vous
pouvez déjà acheter
des enfants du sperme qui va vous donner
un enfant avec des yeux bleus ou des
enfants plus intelligente d'autres je
pense que ça c'est dangereux on peut
aussi aujourd'hui via internet faire
porter son enfant parce que la femme n'a
pas envie de le porter par par une femme
aux philippines à qui on l'a versé 10
mille euros donc toutes ces choses là
c'est une dérive inquiétante je pense
que notre société
je pense qu on déconstruit vraiment on
se demande d'ailleurs qui est ce qu'il
ya vraiment derrière tout ça c'est à
dire on sait pas vraiment les minorités
qui sont cachés derrière derrière c'est
noir pourquoi emmanuel macron a besoin
de faire passer cette loi là en ce
moment et ce qu'il veut ce rapport se
rattacher les électeurs dans la main
pour les élections à venir on sait pas
trop on sait pas trop alors la position
ouverture de des pma aux couples de
femmes et aux femmes seules
mais pas de prise en charge par la
sécurité sociale pour ces nouveaux
bénéficiaires est ce que ça serait tout
de même acceptable pour vous pas tout à
fait la question est ce dont on a peur
c'est que derrière le mariage pour tous
on avait dit il y aura pas de pma il n'y
aura pas de gp
aujourd'hui on part de la pma à l'avant
ce projet de loi et on dira pas de gp à
la gt1 c'est la gestation pour autrui et
donc ces pays une femme ou demain
peut-être un utérus artificiel pour
porter des enfants pensent que voilà
pour le bien de l'enfant
on parle d'écologie aussi beaucoup en ce
moment je pense que l'écologie c'est pas
uniquement
c'est une à l'écologie mais n'a pas
jusqu'à l'homme et et voilà il faut
qu'elle soit intégrale cette écologie
départ uniquement une écologie nature
alors en séance un nombre d'élus devrait
s'opposer également aux modes de
filiation retenu par les députés pour
les enfants des couples de femmes conçu
par pma sa fragiliserait le code civil
selon la république n 1 co rapporteur de
la commission spéciale c'est également
votre avis oui bien sûr c'était amusant
parce que les slogans
alors je vais pas vous les chanter à la
télé mais les slogans
étais je sais pas si vous m'entendez
encore voilà donc expliquant c'était un
père une mère c'est élémentaire ou alors
l'autre slogan c'était c'était je sais
plus et attendez je retrouve sont
évalués à papa pâte est fantastique
maman maman maman tu es unique voilà
toujours seul cette recherche pour le
pour l'enfant le bien de l'enfant
d'avoir un papa une nouveau tout
simplement
alors c'est pas quelque chose de c'est
pas des c'est un viol en quoi c'est pas
compliqué c'est quelque chose d'assez
les dires de celle écolo et là c'est
simple merci en tout cas franck e
mouvant où l'on vous entendez mais vous
avez été un petit peu basculer à
l'envers mais vous étiez toujours avec
nous basculer à l'envers au niveau de
l'image bien évidemment merci à vous
d'avoir été en direct sur rt france et
du côté de l'assemblée nationale ce sont
les débats sur le projet de loi
séparatisme qui se poursuivent les
députés se penchent depuis hier sur ce
texte qui entend lutter contre
l'islamisme radical
au total 70 articles vont être examinés
près de 2000 650 amendements ont été
déposés
parmi les points d'achoppement
l'instruction à domicile elle n en ligne
ou encore la neutralité du service
public propose d'écouter ces quelques
députés voit la loi sur le séparatiste
elle va dans le bon sens mais elle va
pas assez loin sur des questions clés
comme le voile parce que le premier
geste séparatistes et de voile et sa
petite fille de quatre ans donc quand on
voi des enfants dans des poussettes etc
on nous dit que c'est pas du séparatisme
je sais pas ce que c'est et puis
deuxième point c'est l'immigration c'est
que si on contrôle pas le flux
on pourra pas gérer l'assimilation ce
qui manque c'est tout le volet de
programmation de rattrapage en ferme
éducative d'insertion président de la
république lui-même disait c'est sur nos
échecs que ceux nourris l'islamisme et
donc il faut réparer ses échecs ça c'est
pas dans le texte
c'est dommage parce que du coup il est
un peu unijambiste elle c'est à dire par
exemple que quand vous concentrer dans
les mêmes quartiers des gens qui ont un
niveau de réussite scolaire très
inférieur aux autres ou favorisées par
l'échec social par l'échec éducatives ou
favorisées en réalité le discours de
ceux qui disent la france veut pas de
vous c'est pas vrai mais et ça leur
donne du champ et il faut couper ce
champ là pour qu'ils aient pas ensuite
des personnes un peu plus faible si
j'ose dire
retourner contre nous comme des armes
tuent pas défavorables sur l'esprit mais
en réalité c'est une une loi qui
arrivent à éviter quasiment tous les
problèmes donc elle fait mine de rien le
problème alors qu'elle ne règle aucun
c'est essentiellement une petite page de
promotion du ministre de l'intérieur qui
cherche à montrer qu'il est très très
ferme sur les valeurs alors que comme je
vous dis par exemple la question du
voile la question de la radicalisation
la question du terrorisme sont pas
vraiment évoqué et direction à présent
la russie l'opposant alexeï navalni
vient d'être condamné à trois ans et
demi de prison par le tribunal de moscou
où il devrait passer deux ans et demi en
prison raison du temps déjà passé en
résidence surveillée elle ses partisans
ont appelé à descendre immédiatement
dans la rue on retrouve tout de suite
sur place en direct notre correspondant
antoine claireaux à moscou antoine
bonsoir vous êtes sur place
l'appel at il été entendu
[Musique]
ou tout à fait je suis sur place je suis
à l'entrée de la place où les partisans
dans l'excès navali ont appelé ses
sympathisants à se rendre sitôt le
verdict annoncé alors pour l'instant
cela ressemble beaucoup au rassemblement
de dimanche dernier à savoir la place
qui est entièrement bouclé entièrement
verrouillé par les forces de l'ordre une
présence policière très importante dans
le centre de la capitale les quatre ou
cinq stations de métro les plus proches
ont été fermées résultat les gens se
pressent dans les avenues et dans les
rues adjacentes toutes ces avenues qui
mène vers cette place qui se trouve
réellement au coeur de la capitale russe
alors cet appel à descendre dans la rue
a été lancée sitôt le verdict annoncé un
verdict de trois ans et demi de prison
ferme pour rappel alexeï navalni avait
été condamné en 2014 dans une affaire de
détournement de fonds à trois ans et
demi de prison avec sursis et c'est donc
cette condamnation qui a été transformé
en peine de prison ferme alors vous
l'avez évoqué il ne va pas purgé cette
peine de trois ans et demi de prison
mais un petit peu moins car il a passé
quelques mois en résidence surveillée ce
sont donc deux ans et huit mois de
prison ferme qui l'attendent
antoine les réactions internationales ne
se sont pas fait attendre à la suite de
ce verdict
oui tout à fait les états unis par
exemple ont rapidement réagi via un
communiqué du secrétaire d'état qui a
appelé la russie à libérer immédiatement
et sans conditions alexeï navalni même
son de cloche du côté de paris emmanuel
macron a même dans un tweet déclaré
qu'il était que cette condamnation était
inacceptable des réactions similaires
ont été entendus également à berlin ou
encore à londres de quoi susciter une
réaction de la porte parole de la
diplomatie russe maria sharapova qui
pour elle ces réactions ne sont qu'un
copier-coller sergey lavrov a également
commenté cet après midi la présence de
diplomates étrangers lors de l'audience
d'alexei navali il a commenté en
estimant qu'il s'agissait là d'une
interférence dans les affaires internes
à la russie le kremlin a également réagi
au cours de la journée
il a dit que ce serait une bêtise si
l'union européenne venait à conditionner
ses relations avec la russie
au regard de la sphère navalni merci
antoine gayraud en direct de moscou et
en pleine affaire un appel ni la france
appelle l'allemagne a abandonné le
projet de gazoduc north stream ii un
message adressé par le secrétaire d'état
aux affaires européennes mais le
gouvernement allemand rappelé son
attachement au projet ont fait le point
avec florian lambert
malgré la réticence de paris berlin mise
toujours sur north stream 2 en réaction
de soutien à l'opposant russe alexeï
navalni la france a en effet demandé
purement et simplement l'abandon du
projet de gazoduc reliant notamment la
russie à l'allemagne
nous avons toujours dit que nous avions
les plus grands doutes sur ce projet
dans ce contexte la france est elle
favorable à un abandon
on l'a déjà dit en effet un abandon que
la porte parole du gouvernement allemand
a repoussé en répondant je cite que le
gouvernement fédéral n'a pas modifié sa
position de base côté russe l'appel de
la france envers l'allemagne a abandonné
north stream 2 ne freine pas les espoirs
de voir ce projet conduit à son terme
je n'ai aucun doute que la construction
de ce gazoduc sera achevée parce qu'il
est nécessaire nous en avons besoin
les européens en ont besoin notamment
l'allemagne et nos collègues allemands
on parle ouvertement s'il adopte une
position ferme ne sacrifie pas une
partie de leur souveraineté
ce qui s'est parfois produit s'il ne se
plie pas à la position américaine
alors il sera sans aucun doute achevé
début décembre les travaux avaient
repris dans les eaux allemandes après
avoir été suspendu pendant près d'un an
en raison de sanctions américaines
le projet initié en 2018 totalise 1200
km de liaisons sous marines pour un coût
de plus de 9 milliards d'euros
les situations bien mais n'y est présent
sur la table du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu aujourd'hui une réunion d'urgence
en visioconférence au lendemain du coup
d'état militaire
l'ex dirigeante and sun tzu chi d'autres
responsables de son parti la ligue
nationale pour la démocratie sont
toujours entre les mains de l'armée
birmane
des militaires qui font fi des
condamnations internationales qui se
sont multipliés depuis leur putsch hier
grande émotion notamment dans les pays
d'asie où vivent de nombreux
ressortissants birmans
j'ai l'espoir que les nations unies qui
regroupe de nombreux pays résout la
situation et sorte mon pays de ce qui se
passe en ce moment
nous sommes tous très attristés nous
avons vécu plus de 50 ans seul ou
pouvoir militaire et au moment où nous
pensions enfin obtenir la démocratie
ce coup d'état a lieu quelques heures
avant l'ouverture de l'assemblée
nous sommes extrêmement déçus et
désespéré je suis terriblement
bouleversé
j'ai pleuré toute la journée c'est eux
les méchants comment ont-ils pu faire
une chose pareille
la démocratie est une question pour tous
les peuples dans le monde donc s'il y a
un coup d'état n'importe où et peu
importe la race
chaque peuple dans le monde boycottera
le pays où un coup d'état a eu lieu
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
elle nous reviendrons sur la situation
sanitaire en france l'exécutif choisi
pour l'instant de ne pas re confiner le
pays mais sur quels chiffres ou quelles
études s'appuie-t-il et puis direction
l'italie à contre-courant les bars les
restaurants inscrits les musées ont
rouvert leurs portes le couvre feu reste
marc pons
[Musique]
un certain lien de confiance est rompu
entre le politique et les experts et
même les citoyens on est une société qui
est totalement percuté et on ne peut pas
considérer une démocratie véritablement
l'amplitude de ses possibles et
l'amplitude de ses valeurs
quand elle est à ce point confiné est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment on repart à
zéro par rapport à l'année dernière
la société ne survivra pas à une
succession de confinement une société
c'est pas le confinement
c'est la liberté c'est la créativité
c'est le sentiment d'exister
d'appartenir
comment on va réorganiser le monde est
vrai que la pandémie c'est vivre l'amour
[Musique]
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde je réponds en
appartement on est énervé grenelle
sentiment qu'il faut à chaque fois se
battre ils vivent parfois au bord des
routes nationales pas forcément loin de
paris mais toujours loin de ceux qui les
dirigent
moi j'en ai marre qu'on me fasse un tour
de tracteur etc nous puiserons campagne
il faut savoir c'est une vie différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles ma forêt et dévoile un peu
plus aujourd'hui la france oubliée c'est
montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
la minus mahé compte au moins quatorze
mille militaires et policiers déployés
au mali ou non s'est elle fasse c'est
une mission de paix de la chose unis
mais la vérité c'est qu'elle évolue dans
un environnement difficile quand nous
avons un ennemi un ennemi invisible
un élément qui ne connaît pas les
frontières qui le premier cas la réalité
qui est là pour faire du mal mais grâce
à notre détermination nous sommes très
différents
on a le sentiment c'est une guerre
perpétuelle dans le sahel contre les
terroristes
quel est votre constat la menace et le
risque d'une menace pour vos barres et
que sa réponse également doit être plus
souvent delà de la solidarité
robin
[Musique]
les prévisions de croissance pour
l'année 2000 21 ont jamais été aussi
incertaine bien sûr que vous pouvez
avoir 6% à ce moment là était sur la
table comme le font les états unis 2000
milliards et puis vous aurez de la
croissance simplement il faudra les
rembourser un jour une fois qu'on sera
dans la période est membre
l'atterrissage en douceur à ce moment là
il y aura un certain nombre de
dispositifs qui commenceront à tomber
c'est là que l'on pourra faire l état
des dégâts je vous rappelle que ça n'est
pas le virus qui tue l'économie ce sont
les mesures qu'on a appliqué pour
bloquer l'économie objectivement
personne ne sait ce que sera la
croissance de la france mais aussi de la
plupart des pays européens on peut
simuler une croissance mais une vraie
croissance qui repose sur des
fondamentaux solides
vous n'êtes pas prêt de la voir
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes c'est diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
et
ce qu'on attend un peu de vous c'est les
idées pour en sortir est votre jugement
notamment de la façon dont cette crise
est gérée ce qui a été montré au cours
de la gestion de cette crise c'est le
déficit d'anticipation pour moi la
politique c'est d'abord d'être efficace
dès qu'il ya un manque de cohérence
il ya il ya un manque de fiabilité il ya
un manque de confiance faut vite
retrouver la confiance vous considérer
aujourd'hui que que la france a été plus
mauvaise que beaucoup de nos payes et
étrangers nous sommes le pays qui a
inventé les vaccins avec pasteur dont la
réactivité française n'a pas été à la
hauteur de notre réputation tout le
monde a vu que dès le mois de juillet
les chinois vacciner pourquoi est-ce
qu'on a attendu si longtemps
la question est de savoir mais comment
est-ce qu'on va retrouver un équilibre
en faisant en sorte que les épreuves que
nous subissons actuellement deviennent
des forces et non pas des handicaps du
rav
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième émission tout de suite
voici des titres de l'actualité de ce
mardi 2 février
la crise du coronavirus en france à la
veille d'un énième conseil de défense
les indicateurs sont au rouge
le nombre des hospitalisations et des
réanimations est toujours en hausse en
ile de france le variant enlevé se
répand rapidement à l'aide de
professeurs et missels au monde
le vaccin d'astrazeneca autorisée en
france mais pas recommandé aux plus de
65 ans la france pourrait bien avoir à
se tourner un jour vers le vexin russe
lui est jugé efficace à plus de 91% par
la revue de référence de langue cette
idée elle navigue à contre-courant
depuis hier les bars restaurants et
musées ont rouvert leurs portes en
journée dans les régions de virgules le
virus circule le moins lourd refait est
maintenue sur l'ensemble du territoire
de 22 à 5 heures du matin l'opposant
russe alexeï navalni devrait passer deux
ans et demi en prison à la suite du
verdict aujourd'hui du tribunal de
moscou
ses partisans ont appelé à descendre
immédiatement dans la rue
le détracteur du kremlin est condamnée
pour ne pas avoir respecté les
conditions son contrôle judiciaire
paris londres berlin et washington
appelle à sa libération immédiate ou
moscou dénonce une ingérence aux états
unis joe biden
très actif treize jours après son entrée
à la maison blanche le président
américain est à pied d'oeuvre dans les
dossiers économiques migratoire
sanitaire mais également sur le plan
international
donald trump lui est accusé de trahison
sans précédent par les procureurs
démocrate
[Musique]
en france la veille d'un nouveau conseil
de défense les chiffres dans les
hôpitaux ne sont pas bons avec un niveau
similaire au mois d'avril 2020 hier
triste record de décès également avec
446 morts liées au virus et le variant
onglets qui inquiète bien sûr alors
cette question y at il une autre
alternative qu'un reconfirme ans alors
que nos voisins européens eux ont opté
pour de nouveau en filmant éléments de
réponse avec un maxime a bola la
situation se dégrade mais n'est pas
encore catastrophique pour la première
fois depuis début décembre le nombre de
patients atteints par le cos vide 19
admis en réanimation a dépassé les 3200
un chiffre élevé mais loin d'être au
niveau des pics des 1er et 2nd
confinement en avril dernier plus de
sept mille malades avaient été admis
contre eux près de 5000 mi novembre
par ailleurs les hôpitaux ne sont pas
saturés alors qu'il l'avait été au
printemps dernier 136 % des lits de
réanimation étaient occupés le 8 avril
90 % au mois de novembre et 63% à
l'heure actuelle le nombre de cas de
kovy 19le semble quant à lui se
maintenir en moyenne entre le 23 et le
29 janvier
vingt mille personnes auraient été
contaminées chaque jour en france soit
une augmentation de 1% par rapport à la
semaine précédente
des chiffres qui permettent encore aux
gouvernements d'estimer la situation
sous contrôle
la question d'un confinement se pose
légitimement compte tenu de ces données
mais nous en connaissons l'impact très
lourd pour les français
sur tous les plans ce soir nous
considérons au regard des chiffres des
derniers jours que nous pouvons encore
nous donner une chance de l'éviter
pour autant un facteur bouscule les
comparaisons avec 2020 l'arrivée des
variants du coc vide 19 et notamment le
variant angles estimé bien plus
transmissible comme le montrent les taux
de positivité le variant anglais va
prendre le dessus
on a les premiers résultats en région
parisienne qui ne sont pas bons on était
à 6 % le 7 janvier
on est monté à 15 ou 20 pour cent la
semaine dernière et comme le variés
anglais et 40 à 70% plus contagieux il
va y avoir une accélération de
l'épidémie si on ne fait
significativement rien de plus
c'est ça qui nous fait peur des
résultats qui pourraient bien peser dans
la balance les prochains jours vont donc
être déterminant
le gouvernement devrait être très
attentif aux contaminations quotidienne
et si elle venait à exploser comme
c'était le cas juste avant le second
confinement avec une augmentation de
2000 cas chaque jour un troisième
confinement pourrait se confirmer
et pour en parler nous sommes avec éric
henry médecin généraliste président de
l'association soins aux professionnels
de santé bon soir éric henry est merci
d'être avec nous indicateurs au rouge un
chiffre des hôpitaux on l'a dit haut
niveau similaire du mois d'avril 2020
mais pour l'instant toujours pas de
confinement c'est une décision vous
comprenez le gouvernement est un peu
coincé entre confiné pour protéger la
population et la laisser dehors pour la
protéger psychologiquement puisque les
gens sont très atteints
psychologiquement on les voit dans nos
cabinets on les voit sur notre
plateforme les appels ne cessent pas
donc l'état est coincé et se demandent
s'il faut protéger l'économie coup
protéger la santé donc c'est un dilemme
je comprends qu'ils aient du mal à
prendre la bonne décision
alors dilemme mais des épidémiologistes
on a vu d'ailleurs le professeur sall au
monde ne sont guère rassurants en raison
de ce variant anglais qui risque d'être
là nombre les prochaines semaines est ce
que ce n'est pas reculer pour mieux
sauter haut risque ont peut-être
d'empirer la situation alors les
variances est la nouvelle la nouvelle
donne de ce virus c'est-à-dire que les
convie en temps réel ce que vit un virus
qui fait le tour du monde en permanence
à une vitesse folle la grippe on savait
qu'il y avait des variants que ça
changeait tous les ans et cetera lançant
trouvé qu'un virus qui varie en fait
tous les 3 mois ou tous les 4 mois et
qui nous amène en fait des nouveaux
virus alors ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
l'impact de ces virus sur la population
on a la sensation que levier
actuellement même si la réa et est en
train de monter moins virulent que celui
qu'on avait au mois de mars de l'année
dernière c'est une sensation que j'ai
personnellement je ne peux pas dire
scientifiquement si c'est vrai ou si
c'est pas vrai malgré tout la population
est en train de s'habituer au fait qu'il
y aura toujours des virus dans son
entourage et qui va falloir bien faire
avec la problématique c est ce que nous
vivons toujours avec un masque
dorénavant dans notre pays
ça c'est autre chose et effectivement on
peut se poser la question de l'intérêt
de rester sur cette terre si c'est pour
vivre enfermé dans du plastique est dans
du papier autour du papier cellophane
quoi donc voilà elle est là la question
vous vous êtes 3 en pointe sur la
protection des soignants aujourd'hui
clairement vous êtes inquiet a encore
une fois des niveaux similaires au mois
d'avril 2020 dont les hôpitaux
c'est alarmant c'est alarmant oui parce
que les soignants vont encore repasser
pour une deuxième troisième fois au
rouleau compresseur de prendre en charge
pendant charge c'est votre métier les
gars faut pas relâcher faux pas chez
vous applaudissez génial à daisy alesi
allez-y pendant ce temps là les gens
sont épuisés ils n'ont pas pris de
vacances ils n'ont pas pris de repos
leurs conditions de travail se sont
énormément dégrader leurs horaires de
travail ont augmenté leur rémunération
diminuer leur stress familial à a pris
des ampleurs terrible y aller confie de
valeur au sein des familles au sein des
professionnels etc etc
et là ça crée des tensions internes et
psychique très importante et qui impacte
plus en plus si on a des troubles du
sommeil par la surcharge de travail et
bien là on commence à partir en vrille
et le risque est important mais il faut
pas tout concentrer sur les soignants
français puisque il ya aussi d'autres
tranches qui vont souffrir énormément ce
sont tous ces employeurs tous ces
petites entreprises tous ces gens qui
ont investi leur argent un an avant le
coc vide ou six mois avant qu'ils
voulaient montrer leur boîte et qui vont
se retrouver là avec des bilans négatifs
et avec des banques qui vont sonner à
leur porte et qui ont engagé leurs biens
personnels
là on a aussi un contrecoup qui va être
énorme courant va 2021 il faut
l'anticiper
il faut le prévoir il faut dire à tous
les gens de ne pas rester tout seul on a
créé une plateforme sps pour les
soignants 0 805 23 23 36 elle est utile
aussi pour les policiers avec un autre
numéro maintenant pas pour les étudiants
français
on va leur offrir de plateforme pour les
aider à aller mieux parce que les
étudiants sont en crise et je pense que
il faut générer l'universalité d'un tel
système pour que toutes personnes en
france qui craquent qui ne va pas bien
puisse avoir à sa disposition une
plateforme un psychologue h
la liste un psychiatre pour passer ce
tunnel parce que le tunnel va être un
peu long justement vous qui est en
pointe sur ces problématiques
psychologiques vous êtes à la fois
médecin dont vous voulez bien évidemment
sauver des vies avant tout quel est le
meilleur la meilleure ligne de crête le
meilleur équilibre aujourd'hui il faut
effectivement attendre le plus tard
possible pour procéder à un recompte
finement où il faut faire des mesurettes
comme on le fait aujourd'hui notamment
la fermeture des écoles quand il ya un
cas de variance n'était pas le cas
jusqu'à présent à ce que cela peut
suffire aujourd'hui moi je crois que les
français sont un peu à bout ils ont
beaucoup donné pendant un an et demi je
pense qu'il faut trouver le moyen de
leur donner un peu de liberté et un peu
d'air pour respirer parce que ils vont
craquer ou alors ils vont craquer
psychologiquement et en vallée d'aure
sur notre plate forme et dans nos
hôpitaux ou alors au moment ils vont
s'énerver et on va se retrouver avec des
manifestations des gens qui vont sortir
pour dire qu'ils en ont marre de vivre
dans ce nouveau monde qu'on nous
proposera il n'est pas de la
responsabilité du gouvernement je le
redis c'est la nature qui vient nous
rappeler que nous avons été un peu trop
loin dans ce que nous voulions faire sur
cette terre et qu'il est temps de
réfléchir à fonctionner autrement pour
que notre avenir nous en ayons encore un
donc la démarche elle et elle est là
c'est tout le monde doit repenser sa
propre vie et travailler pour que demain
la planète ne soit pas dans l'état où on
l'a laissé juste avant le coc vide et
ensuite au site au gouvernement de
prendre des bonnes décisions en
entendant que effectivement il faut
protéger mais effectivement il faut un
peu de liberté aux français parce que je
crois qu'ils en ont marre d'être
enfermés dans leur maison en portant des
masques en tenant les papiers à la main
pour pouvoir sortir etc
sait on est arrivé à un je pense au bout
d'un système parce que sinon il ya un
variant de variantes roi varian cinq
variantes dit variant ça ne va jamais
cessé la problématique c'est qu'on a des
tests maintenant pour tt ce tout ce qui
bouge
alors on a des spécialistes qui s'est
remis de la bêtise tout ce qui bouge ce
n'était pas comme ça il ya dix ans testé
pas la honte est alors ils découvrent le
test des tests les tests un moment les
tests c'est bien ça nous met dans cette
situation enfin les vaccins surtout vous
y croyez vous en tant que médecin
il se murmure de plus en plus
précisément que les vaccins ne sont pas
efficaces notamment sur le
vaccin sur le brillant pardon brésilien
est ce que ce genre d'information est ce
que ces temps de saugeen csr à se faire
peur ou c'est une réalité
malheureusement avec laquelle on doit
faire je crois que les jambons ont pris
beaucoup de deuxième degré dans cette
affaire puisqu'ils ont bien vu qu'on
courait derrière les masques on ne
devait pas en prendre on en a eu
on devait pas testé on a testé on devait
tester beaucoup on a testé peut on a
testé dans un vrai bazar
en fait on court derrière ce virus on
passe notre temps à essayer de le
rattraper
je pense que c'est trop tard ça court
les variants vont courir ils vont
s'appeler brésil afrique du sud
angleterre guatemala on va en voir
sortir de partout parce qu'on fera un
test combat touré qui d'un petit variant
voilà dans sa protéine qui qui qui va
faire l'intelligence d'un grand
spécialiste qui va nous sortir les
vaccins oui de toute façon c'est ce qu'à
protéger
depuis les années 60 tout le monde tout
le monde a oublié ses vaccins qui a
sauvé de la variole c'est le vaccin qu'à
sauver de la grippe etc
moi je crois au vaccin le problème c'est
qu'on court derrière la bestiole et
qu'on va à chaque fois est obligé de
refaire un vaccin qui va peut être
arriver juste au moment où un autre
variant arrive donc les vaccins arrivent
va sinon toute façon on n'a pas le choix
20 sinon balle sinon au plus tout ce
qu'on peut faire ensuite les labos vont
tourner derrière le problématique de la
bosse et qu'on voit bien que quand ils
ont une panne c'est le monde entier qui
s'arrête et qu'on est devenu énormément
dépendant des laboratoires c'est plus le
politique qui gouverne seul laboratoire
ça aussi c'était un ange et on l'avait
vu arriver que le médicament qu'il
fabriquait tous en inde où tous en chine
on avait perdu tout en france la
fabrication des médicaments je pense
qu'il faut revenir à une fabrication
européenne avoir une base européenne
avoir un conseil scientifique européen
avec des rôles recherche européenne et
non pas française allemande et c'est ça
va de redessiner tout système de santé
mondiale et surtout il faut penser à
l'europe et l'europe doit s'équiper pour
être à la hauteur de de tels enjeux
merci beaucoup et éric harvey médecin
généraliste président de l'association
soit aux professionnels de santé
emmanuel macron a réuni ce soir les
grands acteurs justement pharmaceutique
français et européens
le président a tenté de répondre à cette
question comment soutenir la production
de vaccins il a en tout cas qu'on me que
tous les adultes français pourront
bénéficier d'un vaccin d'ici à la fin de
l'été aujourd'hui nous sommes en train
de dérouler notre campagne de
vaccination elle se déroule au rythme
qui était prévu alors ça peut paraître
trop lent quand on se compare à d'autres
pays qui avait fait d'autres paris qui
sont aussi des pays qui comme le royaume
uni sont des îles dont peuvent
fonctionner différemment ou les états
unis d'amérique qui eux ont acheté
massivement les tout premiers vaccins
mais je défends la stratégie que nous
avons adoptée avec l'allemagne avec
l'union européenne qui est précisément
de vacciner en européen donc aujourd'hui
nous allons continuer de d'abord nous
concentrer sur les plus fragiles c'est à
dire nos aînés et nos concitoyens qui
les sont les plus vulnérables dans
quelques semaines c'est à dire début
mars nous aurons vacciner l'ensemble des
pensionnaires de maisons de retraite ce
qu'on appelle les ehpad qui ont souhaité
80% souhaiter ça représente environ 500
mille de nos concitoyens ils seront tous
vaccinés début mars on aura vacciner
largement au delà de ces établissements
dans cette période aussi les plus de 75
ans nous allons continuer cette
stratégie et d'ici à la fin de l'été
nous aurons proposé en france à tous les
français adultes qui le souhaitent un
vaccin et ces deux informations
importantes y est donc à la lutte contre
le corps un avis russe aujourd'hui
astrazeneca le vaccin est autorisée en
france mais pas recommandé aux plus de
65 ans le vaccin russe pour me lever se
réduit efficace à plus de 91 % la plus
haute validation scientifiquement
possible puisque c'est la revue médicale
de référence de l'endss est validée par
des experts indépendants qui l'affirment
reste maintenant à obtenir
évidemment l'assentiment la validation
de l' agence européenne du
médicaments alors de quoi peut-être pas
lier un jour la pénurie de vaccins en
europe justement l'europe qui est parti
plus tard mais c'était la bonne décision
se défend ursula von der leyen qui
répondait aux critiques concernant la
lenteur de vaccination dans l'ue des
présidente de la commission européenne
qui épinglent a indirectement la
stratégie de londres le royaume uni à
démarrer plus rapidement la vaccination
de sa population plus de 9 millions de
doses ont déjà été administrées
administrés outre manche et londres
qu'ils mènent depuis hier une vaste
opération de dépistage huit zones de
l'angleterre sont concernés après la
découverte de 11 cas de variants sud
africain ces derniers jours objectif des
pistes et 80000 personnes et pour
faciliter les choses une équipe de
volontaires a décidé de se déplacer à
domicile est là mais jane dans le sud
ouest de londres
des bénévoles se mobilisent pour faire
du porte à porte et proposer des kits de
dépistage
je travaille à la maison depuis le 18
mars dernier
donc c'est très agréable d'être dans ma
communauté et d'aider là où nous le
pouvons et de savoir que les gens sont
vraiment chez eux pour participer à
cette étude et à la recherche
ils sont une centaine de volontaires
faire le tour du quartier à pied pour
distribuer ces tests de dépistage à
faire soi même
une initiative bien accueillie par les
habitants je suis assez calme parce que
je reste à la maison donc rien ne
changera mais je pense que c'est bien
parce que plus nous faisons de tests
plus nous découvrons deux personnes qui
auraient dû rester à la maison et
prendre des précautions pour ne pas
aller ailleurs
dix mille kits de dépistage seront
distribués à woking d'ici à vendredi
soir les bénévoles doivent ensuite
récupérer les tests les autorités
sanitaires britanniques veulent
effectuer un recensement massif pour
savoir dans quelle mesure le variant sud
africain s'est répandue le ministère de
la santé et des affaires sociales nous a
demandé d' éradiquer ce variant sud
africain
donc plus nous testerons les personnes
dans la région nous pensons qu'il ya un
risque que nous pourrons identifier
celles qui en sont atteintes
nous pourrons alors abordé les points
vraiment importants qu'il s'agisse de
l'isolément du conseil du gouvernement
sur la manière de traiter des cases une
centaine de cas du variant sud africains
ont été détectés au royaume-uni une
souche susceptibles d'être plus
contagieuse d'où l'inquiétude des
autorités britanniques
le gouvernement a interdit toutes les
liaisons aériennes directes en
provenance de l'afrique du sud
londres a également fermé ses frontières
à une trentaine de pays jugés à risque
le portugal à présent submergé par la
troisième vague un pays durement frappé
en proportion de sa population de 10
millions d'habitants alors que la
population est confinée depuis le 15
janvier dernier les hôpitaux sont eux
saturé à tel point que le gouvernement a
fait appel à l'aide internationale
l'allemagne a annoncé l'envoi ce
mercredi de huit médecins et de
personnel soignant qualifié ainsi que de
quelques 150 appareils de perfusion et
150 lits médicaux le bilan depuis le
début de la vente de l'épidémie s'est
levé hier à près de 13 mille morts dont
plus de 5500 sur le seul mois de janvier
et retour progressif à la vie normale en
italie depuis hier musée magasins et
restaurants ont rouvert
de quoi redonner tout son charme à la
capitale et raviver les visiteurs syrie
l abbé la vie des bulles pleurs les
portes s'ouvrent l'émerveillement est
intacte après presque trois mois de
fermeture
les quelques visiteurs profit de la
réouverture des musées ce lundi en
italie grâce au passage en niveau jaune
de certaines régions musées restaurants
ou encore magasins et salons de coiffure
peuvent reprendre leurs activités
mais les professionnels de la région du
latium dont remet la capitale reste
vigilant face à la menace épidémique qui
plane toujours sur le pays
88 jours est la plus longue période de
fermeture de l'histoire de ces musées
cela a été compliqué nous rouvrons en
toute sécurité
quiconque viendra nous rend
visite peut être sûr qu'il sera bien
surveillé et contrôlé pour les visiteurs
c'est l'occasion de vivre certain moment
inespéré se retrouver seul dans des
lieux en principe bondés de touristes en
provenance du monde entier en 2019 remet
accueilli près de 10 millions de
personnes
c'est vraiment étrange de ne pas voir
plus de deux personnes dans la chapelle
sixtine et les couloirs vides
c'est un rêve je dois dire la vérité
ils ont très bien agi nous avons trouvé
des musées accueillant je suis satisfait
de la manière dont ils agissent en
termes de sécurité dans la période
historique que nous traversons
en guise de surprise de bienvenue dans
l'enceinte du colisée un concert de
musique classique donné par trois
solistes du conservatoire sainte cécile
un moment de partage qui redonne espoir
et sourire aux quelques italiens
présents si aujourd'hui l'épidémie
ralentit par rapport aux états voisins
la botte reste l'un des pays les plus
endeuillé d'europe par la crise du coup
vos navires us et pour parler de la
situation en italie nous sommes en
direct depuis catane en sicile avec
fabien gilot enseignant à l'université
de turin
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir fait bien gibeau merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
que la plupart des pays européens
renforcent la restriction l'italien a
donc décidé de rouvrir on l'a vu musées
restaurants et bars pour quelle raison
une raison économique
il ya bien sûr plusieurs raisons de ce
choix bien sûr il ya le facteur
économique ça c'est évident puisque
l'italie étant un pays basé sur la
restauration des sur le touriste il est
évident que ces restaurants et musées
devenait problématique mais il ya
également en général des chiffres est
encourageant et puis je crois que pour
l'état italien aujourd'hui c'est une
sorte de test de tentative puisque les
chiffres sont encourageants
eh bien nous revoilà population aussi à
ses responsabilités à être raisonnables
même avec mes autorisations sortie de
manière de faire repartir l'économie
tout en faisant très attention et en
respectant les gestes barrières et en se
faisant tout de ne pas trop voyager
justement pour les états alors on a vu
aussi évidemment des révoltes 1 dans les
pays voisins
plus au nord 1 le danemark notamment les
pays bas un expert en italien walter
reed tchad et en santé publique
conseillère du ministre italien de la
santé a déclaré chez vous actuellement
il est extrêmement difficile de proposer
des mesures sévères en raison de la
résistance des politiques et de
l'opinion publique est ce qu'on en est
là également en italie
on craint
vraiment la fronde de la population
alors il ya plusieurs problèmes puisque
bondir le gouvernement italien est
également aux crises politiques
actuellement il n'ya plus au
gouvernement une phase de réflexion d'un
mouvement du gouvernement peut-être
qu'au changement du président du conseil
dans la semaine ou un troisième
gouvernement et tous étaient comptés
dans tous les cas il est évident aussi
que en un sens les choix qui pourrait
être vraiment stratégiques et très forts
sont un peu en suspens c'est plus les
régions aujourd'hui décide actuellement
des restrictions qu'on pourrait faire
l'état met un lien décida en général de
relations générales et après chaque
région gère de façon locale de manière à
maintenir des normes de sécurité selon
marc vivien d'énormes efforts justement
la vénétie également mais dans
l'ensemble on va dire que vu la crise
politique actuelle qu'il ya le
gouvernement italien les décisions
importantes sont aussi au moins pour
cette semaine alors justement vous
parlez des régions il faut préciser que
les peaux et la sardaigne la sicile où
vous êtes l'ombrie et la province de
bolzano autonomes sont restés au niveau
d' alerte orange la situation était
préoccupante particulièrement dans ces
régions le dire il ya plusieurs facteurs
différents selon les régions bien sûr un
des secteurs bien entendu c'est aussi
locales parfois pour la 6 6 par exemple
c'est le président de la région qui a
aussi voulu rester dans une zone plus
orange pour tenir plus la population il
va y avoir des grands événements aussi
culturelle ce mois ci en italie
le carnaval qui est très senti surtout
nord de l'italie va y avoir la fête de
sainte agathe à catane cette semaine qui
est une fête qui portent des centaines
de milliers de personnes dans la ville
donc il y a aussi peut-être qu'une
préoccupation par rapport à d'autres
événements culturels qui pourrait
provoquer justement des risques
sanitaires et donc il y as se maintient
dans certaines régions de la situation
rouge mais les couleurs sont toujours
assez relative en général puisque la
région peut toujours aussi décidé de
modifier certaines lois de ces zones de
ces normes de ces de ses choix
politiques donc par exemple pour la
scolarité pour les écoles chaque région
qu'elle soit jaune orange rouge à
l'impossibilité de gérer
mais le souhaitent de rouvrir ou de
fermer les écoles en tout cas l'om est
celle pourtant averti qu'il était trop
tôt 1 pour assouplir assouplir les
restrictions comment réagir la
population italienne ce qu'elle est à la
fois peut être soulagé que la vie se
desserre un peu mais tout de même
inquiète que c'est l'ex a eu des
conséquences compliqué on se souvient
que l'italie a été à l'origine de cette
épidémie en europe en tout cas a
durement souffert et beaucoup
d'interrogations
paradoxalement finalement cette crise du
coc vite cette semaine est passé un peu
au second plan de l'actualité puisqu'il
ya plus de gouvernement et que c'est un
peu la grande occupation est ce qu'il y
aura une majorité mais ce qu'il y aura
des élections anticipées
on va certainement y majorité mais
forcément on va dire la situation
politique a plus le parent d'un point de
vue d'actualité il est évident que les
italiens en général sont plutôt
satisfaits de redécouvrir le plaisir
d'aller au restaurant de redécouvrir le
plaisir d'aller dans les cafés mais il
ya très certainement un facteur au
ciseau traumatisme je t'entends pas par
rapport aux italiens que je fréquente
une certaine attention générale pas
faire attention dans tous les cas ne
part justement replonger et je pense
qu'il ya un certain sens des
responsabilités merci beaucoup en tout
cas fabien j'ai bon enseignant à
l'université de turin pour avoir évoqué
cette situation en italie dont quelques
instants rester avec nous parlerons de
la condamnation à de la prison ferme de
l'opposant russe alexeï navalni pour
violation de son contrôle judiciaire
ses partisans ont immédiatement appelé
sur les réseaux sociaux à manifester à
moscou et puis direction les états unis
joe biden très actif treize jours après
son entrée à la maison blanche le
président américain est à pied d'oeuvre
dans les dossiers économiques migratoire
sanitaires et internationaux
[Musique]
mon
vous êtes né dans la musique vous êtes
né dans une famille d'artistes désir
révélée brutalement par la prise de
conscience de concerts symphoniques qui
m'a donné envie d'être chef d'orchestre
ça a balayé tout le reste c'est un acte
d'amour la musique pour vous oui mais
l'art en général vous savez ça permet de
mieux se connaître ça permet de mieux
partager c'est la part d'humanité
incontournable et indispensable à
l'évolution de tout être humain quand
vous entendez pata pata pata pata pata
pata pata pata pata pata papa par an
pathamathan vous avez envie de faire ça
l'est il faut que leur qu'istres groove
la musique c'est la traduction la plus
poétique de la vie si vous mettez pas la
vie des évidemment on s'embête il faut
sortir les notes de leurs univers
carcéral
mais il faut jouer ce qui a entre les
notes et avant tout c'est le rythme et
la pulsation et ça c'est fondamental
pour entraîner et l' enthousiasme des
musiciens et celui du public
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes comment ces mecs-là
arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi je
pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose
d'inusité gilet jaune c'était des
valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas d'oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct il y a quand
même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il ya à peu près un enfant sur deux en
france qui est soit victime soit hauteur
de cyber violence sur internet un
contenu haineux de quelqu'un qui dit à
une fillette de 8 ans on va te suicider
ça ça doit être retirée immédiatement il
n'ya aucun débat à avoir sur ce retrait
là parce que ça ça fait des suicides la
loi le condamne déjà c'est déjà interdit
de faire ça bien sûr mais c'est juste
que 1 et diaphane ne l'appliquent pas la
justice est lente et c'est très
problématique qui doit prendre ce rôle
de régulateur la loi peut aider
l'éducation peut aider selon les
différentes catégories d'attaquants et
d'attaquer une erreur de la loi via ça a
été de tout mettre dans le même panier
sous le sous le nom et no line quel rôle
pour les réseaux sociaux on a vu les big
for books les gaffes à s'organiser pour
annuler quelqu'un sur internet ce
quelqu'un c'était donald trump quand il
s'agit d'un bannissement si général pour
moi ce n'est pas aux gaffes à et aux
réseaux sociaux à dolhain des
entreprises privées de prendre cette
décision mais ça doit être à la justice
de prendre cette décision
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt francs
si vous nous rejoignez 21h30 heure
française et direction la russie
d'opposants alexeï navalni vient d'être
condamné à trois ans et demi de prison
par le tribunal de moscou
il devrait passer deux ans et demi en
détention en raison du temps déjà passé
en résidence surveillée ses partisans
ont appelé à descendre immédiatement
dans la rue le point sur place avec
notre correspondant à moscou antoine
frérot
je suis à l'entrée de la place où les
partisans d'alexey navali ont appelé ses
sympathisants à se rendre sitôt le
verdict annoncé alors pour l'instant
cela ressemble beaucoup au rassemblement
de dimanche dernier à savoir la place
qui est entièrement bouclé entièrement
verrouillé par les forces de l'ordre une
présence policière très importante dans
le centre de la capitale les quatre ou
cinq stations de métro les plus proches
ont été fermées résultat les gens se
pressent dans les avenues et dans les
rues adjacentes toutes ces avenues qui
mène vers cette place qui se trouve
réellement au coeur de la capitale russe
alors cet appel à descendre dans la rue
a été lancée sitôt le verdict annoncé un
verdict de trois ans et demi de prison
ferme pour rappel alexeï navalni avait
été condamné en 2014 dans une affaire de
détournement de fonds à trois ans et
demi de prison avec sursis et c'est donc
cette condamnation qui a été transformé
en peine de prison ferme alors vous
l'avez évoqué il ne va pas purgé cette
peine de trois ans et demi de prison
mais un petit peu moins car il a passé
quelques mois en résidence surveillée ce
sont donc deux ans et huit mois de
prison ferme qui l'attendent les états
unis par exemple ont rapidement réagi
via un communiqué du secrétaire d'état
qui a appelé la russie à libérer
immédiatement et sans conditions alexeï
navalni même son cloche du côté de paris
emmanuel macron a même dans un tweet
déclaré qu'il était que cette
condamnation était inacceptable des
réactions similaires ont été entendus
également à berlin ou encore à londres
de quoi susciter une réaction de la
porte parole de la diplomatie russe
maria sharapova qui pour elle ces
réactions ne sont qu'un copier-coller
sergueï lavrov a également commenté cet
après midi la présence de diplomates
étrangers lors de l'audience d'alexei
navali il a commenté en estimant qu'il
s'agissait là d'une interférence dans
les affaires internes à la russie le
kremlin a également réagi au cours de la
journée
il a dit que ce serait une bêtise si
l'union européenne venait à conditionner
ses relations avec la russie
au regard de la sphère navalni et pour
en parler nous sommes avec karine et
béchu golovkov professeur invité à
l'université d'état de moscou mme vo
soir merci d'être avec nous doit tous
être surpris ce soir par le verdict de
ce procès des vanniers bonsoir non je
pense qu'il n'y a strictement aucune
surprise quant au verdict cela fait très
longtemps que la vanille tire sur la
corde reproduire et choses simplement et
la corde rompu la patience de la russie
a pris fin donc ça fait quand même des
années que la vanille est en liberté
conditionnelle ça fait des années qu'il
a se positionne comme étant au-dessus
des lois la loi rien simplement de le
rattraper il faut comprendre que le fait
de voir sa peine de prison transformée
en prison ferme quand on a
systématiquement violé les conditions de
sa conditionnelle c'est quelque chose de
tout à fait normal donc simplement la
vanille et traiter ici comme n'importe
quel citoyen russe auraient été traitées
sauf que un citoyen russe ont été
traitées ainsi beaucoup plus tôt des
oliviers alors alex n avait ni ne
pouvait pas ignorer ce qui l'attendait
en russie il a décidé de revenir sur le
sol russe comment l'expliquez une
stratégie de sa part de vouloir revenir
justement dans son pays peut-être
pourrait être victimiser où il faut
chercher une autre piste non tout
d'abord effectivement oui c'est un
scénario s'est monté ça se voit il
suffit de voir le nombre de
représentants diplomatiques aujourd'hui
au tribunal pour voir que derrière des
mises en scène absolument parfaite
mais rappelons quand même que navali n'a
pas été si près c'est que ça de rentrer
dans son pays
et c'est justement ce qui pose problème
aujourd'hui puisque
il a été quatre semaines en prison il
avait ses 80 ans en allemagne
fin octobre le service d'exécution des
peines russa a commencé à lui aux
brouillons demandant où il se trouvait
d'après ses réponses au tribunal il
estimé que tout le monde était au
courant et qu'il avait autre chose à
faire que de répondre donc finalement en
fait il a commencé à réagir fin novembre
vaguement et il a fallu réellement qu'il
y ait une menace de poursuites
judiciaires pour qu'ils rentrent
finalement en russie on peut pas dire
qu'il soit rentrer tout de suite en bon
citoyen conscient de ses obligations pas
du tout il est possible aussi que ses
sponsors commencent à trouver leurs
factures un petit peu lourde que
maintenant il faille rentabiliser ce que
l'on voit parfaitement avec les
manifestations organisées dès son retour
puisque sac chacun savait très bien que
ayant violé gestion lussan il allait
être interpellé l'arrivée et c'était
d'ailleurs le but et avec le cirque la
mise en scène qu'il a faite au tribunal
qui à la limite d'une injure au système
judiciaire parce que de telles
politisation d'une affaire techniquement
juridique
alors on le sait avec salavat n'y ait
des ambitions politiques quel avenir
pour cet opposant politique à vladimir
poutine
son avenir est pour l'instant
principalement dans la presse
occidentale et dans les chancelleries
occidentales
disons que lorsque l'on regarde le
nombre de personnes et l'âge des
personnes qui peut mettre dans les rues
il est évident qu'il est beaucoup plus
intéressant s'il est vivant en prison ou
ciment en étant une victime
sacrificielle puisque pour l'instant ce
moment là sérieusement besoin donc tout
l'intérêt de ses sponsors c'est de le
voir en prison réellement dans la rue et
en pleine liberté il ne représente
quasiment rien parce que finalement il
n'a rien à proposer et il n'est pas là
pour proposer quoi que ce soit il n'est
pas une alternative n'est pas une
opposition constructive
il est là pour détruire un système et la
focalisation qu'il a dans ses discours
face à vladimir poutine montre à tel
point c'est à la limite de la
mégalomanie
parce que lorsqu'il parle dans ce qu'il
déclare que les filles sont des millions
dans la rue
personne n'osera ya à faire pour
l'instant il a déjà du mal à mettre
quelques milliers de personnes dans la
rue dans toute la russie
donc nous sommes quand même assez loin
de grands mouvements populaires de
millions de personnes qui mangent le
crime alors en tout cas l'europe
occidentale ne le voit pas de de la même
manière jusqu'aux états unis d'ailleurs
il ya eu des réactions très rapide
l issue de ce procès longs berlin paris
moscou tous demandent sa libération
immédiate à ce que l'on doit craindre
une détérioration encore plus grande des
relations entre l'europe occidentale le
monde occidental et la russie
effectivement il va y avoir et l'ia déjà
ces derniers temps une détérioration
grandissant des relations entre la
russie d'une part et la russie est un
pays occidental je dirais plutôt et le
mans globalise puisque nous sommes face
à un conflit idéologique d'une part un
monde unipolaire donc le baliste
américaine au centre et d'autre part les
visions du monde pluriel qui est
proposée par la russie sont des visions
qui sont entièrement compatibles donc
l'arrivée de baida à la présidence aux
états unis ne fait que relancer encore
plus fort ce combat qui est porteuse
états unis par les démocrates
principalement
donc oui effectivement d'autre part nous
voyons comme une faiblesse politique un
alignement idéologique des pays
européens et de l'union européenne en
tant qu'entité qui d'ailleurs existe
pour cela
donc effectivement la dégradation état
est à suivre de certainement peut-être
de nouvelles sanctions sont encore à
attendre et la question de main stream 1
2 revient à nouveau sur devant la scène
et l'on voit bien ici d'ailleurs à quel
point tout ce jeu sert principalement
les intérêts atlantis des américains et
de tous les entretenir votre merci
beaucoup karine déchets call of qu'aux
professeurs mitaine l'université d'état
de moscou d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france
et on parlait justement des états unis
des états unis joe biden se montre actif
treize jours après son entrée à la
maison blanche le président américain se
montre à pied d'oeuvre dans des dossiers
économiques migratoire sanitaire mais
également sur le plan international on
fait le point avec quant à mme auclair
le plan de relance premiers points de
négociation entre joe biden m et
républicains le président américain a
reçu ce mardi à la maison blanche
plusieurs sénateurs de l'opposition à
l'ordre du jour le plan de sauvetage de
l'économie contesté par ces derniers les
sénateurs républicains propose de
diviser par trois le budget prévu dans
ce plan de sauvetage c'est le vent
initialement à plus de 1,9 milliard de
dollars
un premier test pour joe biden pour en
savoir plus sur sa volonté de gouverner
dans un esprit de discussion c'était un
très bon échange de points de vue
je ne dirais pas que nous nous sommes
accordés sur un plan ce soir personne ne
s'attendait à ça lors d'une réunion de
deux heures mais nous avons convenu de
poursuivre et de discuter davantage au
niveau des collaborateurs entre nous et
avec le président et la vice-présidente
sur la manière dont nous pouvons
continuer à travailler ensemble sur
cette question très importante
autre priorité de joe biden
l'immigration sur ce point
l'actuel président américain souhaite
prendre une direction drastiquement
opposé à son prédécesseur par le biais
d'un décret joe biden a demandé à ses
collaborateurs de faciliter le processus
de naturalisation
le président des états unis souhaitent
également lever les freins à
l'immigration mise en place par donald
trump
au total neuf millions de migrants sont
éligibles à la nationalité américaine
le président byden crois que les
immigrants sont essentiels à notre
identité nationale est indispensable à
nos aspirations pour l'avenir
l'administration précédente a mis en
place des centaines des politiques qui
vont à l'encontre de notre histoire et
sable caractère de l'amérique comme
terre d'opportunités ouverte et
accueillante pour tous ceux qui viennent
ici à la recherche de protection et
d'opportunités à l'international le
président américain a mis les bouchées
doubles lors de ses premiers jours à la
maison blanche
entre la signature de la prolongation du
traité russo américain new start ou
encore la suspension des ventes d'armes
à l'arabie saoudite et des chasseurs
f-35 aux émirats arabes unis
les relations diplomatiques avec l'iran
sont actuellement en cours de discussion
avec en point d'orgue
l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien enfin
le coup d'état en birmanie constitue le
premier grand test pour joe biden
l'actuel président américain pourrait
profiter de cette occasion pour vouloir
remettre les états unis au premier plan
de la scène internationale c'est la
raison pour laquelle ça a été évoqué
dans les commentaires du président comme
vous le savez nous avons levé les
sanctions les états unis devrais je dire
enlever les sanctions sur la birmanie au
cours de la dernière décennie sur la
base des progrès réalisés vers la
démocratie
l'annulation de ces progrès nécessitera
une révision immédiate de nos lois et
autorité en matière de sanction suivie
d'une action appropriée
outre les dossiers économiques
migratoires et diplomatique joe biden
doit également faire face à la crise
sanitaire
pendant sa campagne il avait annoncé
vouloir vacciner 100 millions
d'américains lors des cent premiers
jours de son mandat
un défi de taille alors que les
etats-unis ont déjà recensé plus de 440
3000 morts depuis le début de la
pandémie
deux semaines après son entrée à la
maison blanche le président biden fait
donc face à la crise du coronavirus les
correspondances à new york de calais
maupin journalistes rt international joe
biden a annoncé que la lutte contre le
coc vide serait une de ses priorités
de même que les défaillances dans ce
domaine était un des sujets qu'il
critiquait le plus chez son prédécesseur
le président n'a pas de plan il n'a rien
préparé
il savait déjà en février à quel point
la crise était grave
il dit qu'il faut reprendre le travail
et s'est débarrassé du coc vide
on ne peut pas relancer le pays sans
avoir d'abord maîtriser locaux vides
le président des etats-unis a été testé
positif aux corridas ce n'est pas de la
politique c'est un rappel fort qu'il
faut prendre ce virus au sérieux je
baille donne dit qu'il a un plan de 200
pages mais la longueur et l'éloquence
d'un document ne garantissent pas son
succès je baille donne commence à peine
et déjà 20 millions
deux doses de vaccin ont disparu ce
mystère pour ainsi dire aubert les
capacités de vaccination rapide du
gouvernement
cela fait une semaine et l'équipe byden
cherche toujours les doses manquant dans
le même temps certaines des communautés
les plus touchées par le caue vides font
face à de graves difficultés dans la
vaccination à los angeles une foule de
manifestants anti vaccins ont bloqué
l'accès aux dogues stadium et empêcher
des gens de recevoir le vaccin
les opérations ont été interrompues
pendant plus d'une heure incroyable si
vous refusez le vaccin très bien mais
des millions d'angelin le veulent seize
mille de vos voisins sont morts donc
dégager le chemin manifestants ne sont
pas le seul problème
new york est en état d'urgence tempête
de neige et les vaccinations se sont
interrompus là bas aussi
tout comme dans l'orégon pour des
raisons météorologiques également faute
de transport certaines personnes n'ont
pas pu revenir recevoir leur seconde
dose à temps les docteurs ont donc
commencé à distribuer les vaccins à qui
ils pouvaient fragile un problème de
réfrigération peu gâché tout un lot
seattle les docteurs ont vacciné aussi
rapidement que possible après une panne
de réfrigérateur lorsque c'est arrivé
la réaction immédiate a été nous devons
injecter ces 1600 doses dans les 12
prochaines heures au travail et à 3h15
du matin
nous y étions arrivés environ la moitié
des américains sont prêts à se faire
vacciner malgré le chaos né parmi les
populations déjà septique
les inquiétudes sont fortes la défiance
le rejet de la vaccination sera un des
obstacles majeurs à l'objectif de joe
biden de sortir rapidement le pays de la
crise
pour le moment la planification apparaît
difficile joe biden ne semble pas avoir
de programme clair mais l'équipe de la
maison blanche a n'a de cesse d'alléguer
de ces bonnes intentions
personne n'avait que les éléments des
plans en cours à l'époque reposer sur la
supposition que des informations
supplémentaires seraient disponibles et
révéler une fois à la maison blanche
mike tyson légende de la boxe américaine
a dit un jour que tout le monde a un
plan jusqu'à ce qu'on se prenne un coup
de poing dans les dents des semble assez
clair à ce stade que les états unis
n'étaient pas préparés pour le crochet
du droit infligée par la pandémie
le temps presse les gens meurent et le
vaccin tant désirée reste nimbée de
chaos et de confusion tiers et pour en
parler nous sommes avec douglas yates
professeur de droit spécialiste de
sciences politiques américaines bonsoir
degrés seuil et merci d'être avec nous
joe biden investit donc depuis 14 ou 14
jours pour commencer à détricoter le
milon de donald trump mais pas surtout
est ce que le fantôme de tram sera
difficile à faire oublier
oui pour l'instant le fandom donald
trump reste un élément de force
d'abord dans le parti républicain parce
que 30 part amassé 180 millions de
dollars après avoir perdu l'élection
il a dépensé que 800 milles donc il a
tenu un trésor pour les campagnes à elle
est républicaine particules mieux qui
sont en face des contraintes des
opposantes prendre un primaire ont peur
dans nos rangs de sa base et de son
argent mais en plus on assez de legacy
de 30 ans d'entendre toujours les
communiqués de ex présidente
et oui il est vraiment le fun dans la
maison blanche
mais joe biden aussi à occuper ces
fonctions très importante et particules
mois il travaille maintenant après avoir
dit tricoter comme on dit le bilan de 30
il commente marc on travaille avec les
législatures ici ça sonne fort ancien
sénateur de trois décennies il a des
amis ils savent comment ces deux rôles
et son conversation avec dix sénateurs
étaient été une réussite du mois
symbolique
évidemment on entend forcément moins la
voix des pros trump aujourd'hui peu
qu'est ce qu'ils deviennent si j'ose
dire est ce qu'ils se taisent aux états
unis où c'est juste qu'on ne les entend
pas en france il y avait un moment où
les gaffes à en couper la prod d'altran
en le sanctionner en enlever ses doigts
de communiquer sur twitter sur facebook
et donc s à 1 1 rendus impuissants les
présidentes communiqué dans ces moyennes
normales
pour l'instant on a l'idée que beaucoup
de gens maintenant ont changé soit dans
le dip web ou dans ou dans les sorties
native mais ils sont désorientés
parce que le moyen de se communiquer
entre eux mêmes et avec le grand public
était enlevée de mes tantes continue à
jouer l'euro avec les influences hier
dans le parti et à et son europe comme
comme leaders de l'opposition restent
fortes mais en plus il y à la division
entre eux dans le parti républicain qui
veut législatives eux abandonné 30 et
les jeunes qui sont de son base et
légendes radical et les nouvelles
générations de républicaine donc non le
soutien de 30 n'a pas disparu mais on ne
l'entendent pas en avait fait une étude
sur les grues bascule dans les
événements du 6 janvier
et on ne trouve qu'un grand parti deux
ne sont pas des radicaux mais sont des
vrais républicains les petites
businessmen les propriétaires et qui
sont radicalisés il reste loyale trompe
et à ses idées
en tout cas de m'interrompre est accusé
de trahison par les procureurs démocrate
qui risque de venir au devant de la
scène à nouveau pour cette raison à quoi
faut-il s'attendre justement il faut
attendre un procès il a viré toute son
équipe des juristes parce qu' ils
racontent donné des consignes de parler
de vols de l'élection donc il ils ont
tous démissionné
il a pris lé nouvel avocat mais qui
veulent faire une alimentation qui
trompe n'était pas responsable pour les
événements mais le le sortie déjà connu
trente ne soit pas en coupe et on n'a
pas dit cette semaine et républicaine en
rejoindre la majorité démocrate mais
quand même son ombre se rattacher par
ces procédures les vraies questions ca
après sept procès est-ce que ce soit
possible pour joe biden de fer dont une
première ce jour des législations avec
une collision bicaméral parce qu après
cette attaque ce temps pour beaucoup de
républicains en train de se montrer
loyal le président démocrate en tout cas
propos de joe biden exemple emblématique
aujourd'hui un joe biden qui a demandé à
son gouvernement de facilité la
naturalisation des 9 millions de
migrants éligibles à la citoyenneté
américaine
très emblématique est fidèle à ce que il
annoncé joe biden oui ok ça sonne
ambitions mais pas pour l'instant
quelque chose qu'il peut faire avec
facilité c'est moins une question d'une
arête présidente signé avec own stylo
bic houde foutra est plutôt un acte
législation y la majorité dans le
chambre de représentante
mais sans les républicaine sans le
soutien des partis républicaine c'est
probable il va gagner son pari
l'organisation de 9 millions dénigrante
c'est une ambition pendant les années
obama mais leur évolution tron pour
changer l'opinion publique et c'est par
certains qui pourrait pousser ça et
gagner son législation de reconstruction
de l'économie et gagner sur son
programme de vaccination et avoir à
accepter toutes ces nominations il y a
les feux partout et en dépit de sa
promesse vers la vote hispanique en
particulier ham joe biden pourrait être
limitée dans sa capacité de régulariser
son scénic ans merci beaucoup d'eau
glacée y est professeur de droit
spécialiste de sciences politiques
américaines d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur arte france ce soir merci à
vous et c'est la fin de cette émission
se retrouvent donc quelques instants
pour un point complet sur l'actualité de
la journée
[Musique]
un certain m confiance est rompu entre
le politique et les experts même les
citoyens on est une société qui est
totalement percuté et on ne peut pas
content